and Jose Mendoza. Thanks to both of you for
being new David Pakman show members and also
want to say thanks to today's longtime sustaining
member of the day, Christine [inaudible],
who has been with us almost five years, signing
up as step one. Staying subscribed is step
two, and I really appreciate folks who have
been with us five, six, seven, even nine years
in some cases, amazingly enough, a sign up@joinpacman.com
there's a coupon code available if you would
like it, which will save you 40% off of your
membership. That coupon code is, this is 2020.
You don't have to use it, but by all means,
feel free. Let's go to the phones at six one
seven, eight three zero 47 50 and see what
is on people's minds today. Let's start with
our color from the afford to three area code
today. Who's calling from four to three?
Am I on
that is you my friend?
Okay, well, uh, I appreciate you having me
on. Of course. I'm calling from the great
city of Chattanooga, Tennessee. Um, yes, a
border city of Tennessee and Georgia e-way.
Um, please have been on my, my, you know,
we've got the 2020 election coming up here
pretty soon. Yup. And me, I, myself a centrist
Libertarian basically, uh, you know, pre-filed
with anybody that really does anything as
long as they don't infringe on my rights kind
of thing. And really the last guy I want to
win the election was in 2012 when Ron Paul
ran.
What'd you like about him?
Isn't that a well, I mean he was pretty simplified,
you know, he was basically for really anything,
uh,
as long as you,
he didn't have, you know, you didn't infringe
on your constitutional rights and, uh, he
was an isolationist, you know, he wanted to
get out of the wars, which by the way, we're
still in the last 20 years and we've spent
trillions of dollars on it, not worked, and
both parties have not worked. And, uh, for
example, the right wing, you've had the rise
of what I called the Uber Patriots. The Uber
people call them the outright, I call them
the Uber Patriots. But, uh, yeah, you've had
the rise of them. And then of course a lot
of people on, uh, on the left, you've kind
of had this divide and that's what's caused
a lot of the people on the left and not win
as much.
I don't know that I agree with that. I think
I agree that the left has not been doing,
not been doing a lot of winning, but I just
saw a pretty good study which shows that the
left is actually less divided than the right
currently. And I find the data motivate a,
a believable. So I don't know that, that I
agree with your assessment that the left has
been doing a lot of losing. I don't think
it's because the left is divided though.
Right. And, uh, this past election, um, if
Bernie had been in, I would have voted for
him cause he's the only one actually somewhat
light. Okay. Um, and Hillary, you know, like
I didn't like her. I didn't like Trump or
either of them. I actually made a long Facebook
post about how I actually think about it.
They're very well connected with each other.
And honestly, I thought, you know, it was
a ploy to keep Bernie out of it.
You think that w w so let's talk [inaudible].
What, what was the ploy to keep Bernie out
by Trump running and Hillary being the nominee
in total was a plot to prevent Bernie from
being the president. You're saying
[inaudible]
yes. I know this sounds crazy, but let me
explain because right. Anyways, um, basically
I believe that because if you look at historically
they've been great friends for years and all
of a sudden, you know, he decides to run as
a Republican. And if you look at his, uh,
political stances, historically, he's a big
flip-flopper. He doesn't stay with one party.
He's never been consistent on anything.
He doesn't stay with one woman. Yeah, I get
it.
Yeah. And another thing too is another phrase
I've heard you couldn't believe in this is
if his tongue was notarized, but anyways,
and
yeah, but hold on a second, but, so let me
ask you, let, let's get to down to the, to
the nitty gritty of it. What overarching group
or, or, uh, entity would coordinate both the
Republican and the democratic nominees in
order to prevent Bernie from being president?
Like who, who, who, who set that up?
[inaudible]
um, well I mean the, uh, democratic national
committees to where he was when they heavily
were for Clinton.
Yes.
Also too, she had the suit. She had the super
packs, which I'm heavily against. I believe
we should get rid of.
I got you. But don't get off track though.
So, so, okay. We know that the DNC favored
Hillary, but where does the conspiracy to
have Trump and Hillary run against each other
to keep Bernie out come from?
Well, I believe in a weird way that Trump
might've bought his way onto the Republican
nominee to, uh, I'm sorry if I'm not making
any sense.
You know, it's not making sense, I think.
I think you're realizing it doesn't really
make sense. Here's, I think here's what happened.
Hillary was the nominee because the DNC favored
Hillary. Trump was the nominee because republicans
lost their minds and he was able to use the
combination of, uh, you know, clever nicknames.
And the idea of being an outsider to an electorate
that was well primed to fall for it, partially
because of their hatred for Obama. I think
that they were two different things that took
place. I don't, I don't agree with your assessment
that there was a unified conspiracy for it
to be Trump versus Hillary so that Bernie
wouldn't be president. That's my view.
Ash. Well, I appreciate that you actually
helped me clarify a little bit. I've just
been kind of confused over this.
All right, good. Well I'm glad, glad to la
your confusion and I really appreciate the
call, but I've got to move on cause I've got
a bunch of people who want to get on here
today.